your next copic vaccine could include a
hundred
million dollars there's a new bill
that's hoping to give folks the
opportunity for that grand prize as an
incentive to get more shots into
people's arms christian casadas joining
us now in studio with how this will work
and who's behind it kristen well guys
sounds like a sweet deal right but the
details are not finalized yet that's
according to congresswoman dina titus
who is behind the effort now she
introduced a bill today that would
create a national lottery
to get more people to get vaccinated
against covet 19.
now you've heard get out and vote well
this is more like get out
the vaccination the congresswoman tells
me that there has been
some vaccine hesitancy but states like
ohio and california
have seen similar efforts which have
basically motivated the community
she has no doubt it will help get more
residents vaccinated against covet 19
and help get the country past the
pandemic now she added that this would
also help reach
president biden's goal of getting 70
percent of adults vaccinated with at
least one shot
and 160 million fully vaccinated by the
fourth of july
it wouldn't be a state lottery it would
be a federal lottery
be run by the treasury department and
the irs
be 100 anonymous people chosen at random
from all around the country
to win a million dollars once they prove
they've gotten the vaccination
well if the bill is approved anyone 18
years or older will be eligible to be
one of
one hundred million dollar prizes now
governor steve syselect
said the state is working on a similar
effort but details on that
still remain unknown and just to clarify
anyone who has received at least
one dose of an fda authorized a vaccine
by the time of the drawing
is eligible for the million dollar prize
it's not just for people
who get the shot after the bill is
passed so the congresswoman hopes
that this will all get approved this
bill will get approved
very very soon so all eyes on that
christian casa is 8 news now